Now, when you're receiving phone calls, there's a couple of things that you must do.
First of all, you want to answer that phone promptly.
Ring one, ring two, ring three; "Hello, this is Tracy."
By three rings, you should pick up that phone.
And what you also want to do is you want to have a smile in your voice.
See, I can't see your face.
So I want to say, "Hey, this is Tracy. Hello."...
...alright? Or however you answer the phone...
...because a smile in your voice will present you as positive and helpful,...
...and what you want to do immediately is find out...
...who you're calling and how you can help them.
Those are just essential things that you have to do when you answer the phone.
Go back and think about tone and all of those things.
You don't want to answer your phone after it's been ringing seven times,...
..."This is Tracy."
Okay, what's my customer going to think?
My caller's going to be afraid, very afraid.
So be positive, be professional, give a smile to that hello.